après 8 jours de combat contre le feu à
Nord métal épuisé les troubles du
pompier d'Antoine Baillargeon pourront
enfin se
reposerais de la même manière mais on
est là pour coacher et puis c'est
l'adrénaline qui nous porte le pompier
prévient que le village s'est
métamorphosé il y a des trains
les 54 pompiers du Nouveau-Brunswick
sont enfin sur le terrain ils prennent
le relève pour combattre les feux plutôt
calme aujourd'hui mais qui menacent
toujours la ville
en fait un excellent travaux pour
protéger nos métal avec les
viens aussi avec peu de personnels c'est
incroyable ce qui ont fait pour sauver
la ville c'est incroyable
et ce n'est pas la seule bonne nouvelle
pour apporter une assistance financière
à la population évacuée une indemnité
forfaitaire de 1500 dollars sera accordé
pour chaque résidence principale évacuée
ici à l'école secondaire de la Sarre le
chef sert plus de 300 repas par jour aux
évacués de Nord métal ici c'est la salle
à manger de la table des chefs
financolino l'endroit devient un repère
pour briser l'isolement les gens sont
capables de se voir entre voisins et ça
les sécuriser beaucoup de pouvoir se
parler entre eux
l'aide financière du gouvernement apaise
aussi cette mère de famille c'est clair
que ça va faire du bien ça soulage je
pense surtout à ceux qui ont perdu les
emplois des deux côtés les évacuer
souhaitent surtout revenir à la maison
soyez patients disent les autorités le
marathon contre le feu vient à peine de
commencer ici Marie-José paquet de
Comores au Canada normale